- [Brooke] Years now since
I graduated--
- Brooke, Brooke,
this is the greatest moment,
Brooke, you have made my fucking life.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk
in this episode 295 of
the #AskGaryVee Show
and this is, you know
what I love about life?
Timing.
This is somebody
that I have an enormous
amount of admiration to.
We're gonna go into it.
We're gonna do phone calls
'cause I think a lot of people
want access to this dude.
He's out and about
but getting access to
him is very difficult
'cause he's busy
so we're gonna do phone calls.
Facebook, put in your phone numbers.
Andy is here and he's
gonna pick some calls.
We'll do that towards the end.
- We're live?
- [Gary] We're live.
- Should I have like put
this on my social media,
I'm doing this?
- You can do whatever the fuck you want,
whatever's good for you.
- Did I mess up guys?
- No, no, you're good.
Unlike normal things that you do,
we have enough social media power
to get you exposure.
Usually people are asking you
because you have so much power.
But that's not what we need to do.
What we need to do is get some
phone numbers from Facebook
for the show.
Scooter Braun is in the building.
I have contemporaries,
people that are 10
years older and younger,
I would say in the way
that I use contemporaries
that I really admire.
Scooter is really genuinely
one of those five or six people
at the top of the list,
not only for his ridiculousness
in accomplishing things that I admire
which is business,
comma, culture, comma,
the most important part,
just a good human being.
We had a pretty fun text exchange
maybe three or four months
ago just on that of like
rooting for you, rooting for you,
not a lot of people with
the kind of parenting
and DNA that we have, families,
there's just so much I can go into,
his brother is one of my dear friends.
I sit on the board of Pencils of Promise
and have been involved with that
but when we met for the first time ever,
eight or nine years ago,
we're waiting outside of Nobu in Midtown,
they're not ready to seat us,
we're just meeting.
My brother AJ's there
which is rare for me to bring my brother
to a meeting back in the
day but the reason was
'cause Scooter and his brother were there.
We're just getting to know each other,
we were put in touch by
CAA or somebody else,
we're just getting to know each other,
the first thing we get into in 30 seconds
is our deep love of the New York Jets
and within 19 seconds of that,
Mark Sanchez, our starting quarterback,
walks by us,
neither of us know him at the time,
and we're like, did that just happen?
Then we get seated next to him,
it becomes this whole classic story
and thus begun a great friendship
and watching, at that point
you were managing Justin,
so you'd already kind of "made
it" into the consciousness
but nowhere to the mogul
impact you're making now.
I'm really glad you're here, Scooter,
thanks for being here.
- Thanks buddy.
- How are you?
- And the admiration
is mutual.
- Thanks man.
- I've watched you do
these from a distance
and we've joked around about
me actually coming here
and finding the time
and I'm excited for this one
because I don't think I'll ever
yell back and forth on a podcast
the way we're probably about to go.
- To your point,
we've been talking about
doing this for quite awhile,
Scooter's cool
and what that means is that he FaceTime's,
not calls or texts,
he's in the culture,
which if you're cool--
- I also like to FaceTime people
to make them feel uncomfortable.
- 100%.
And he's always on the West Coast,
I'm always in bed with
my wife, all this stuff,
'cause weekends,
but what's most fun is that Scooter and I
activate our friendship the
most during football season.
We're both diehard Jets fans
and the fact that out of all the times
we could've possibly done this,
we're doing it literally the Monday
after a third loss in a row.
The rose is super off the bloom
on this season.
- You remember what
I texted you on the chain?
What was the last thing
I texted on the chain?
- I have no clue.
- 'Cause we're on a chain
with a bunch of Jets fans
and the last thing I texted
was this is not fun.
- Yes, it's just not, it's just not.
And so, Scooter, real
quick, knowing my audience,
for the three to six percent,
'cause that's how little it is,
that don't know anything about you,
give me the comic book
number one origin story
'cause I think there's so many things
I admire about your origin story,
I'll bring them up if
you don't get to them
but what is the three minute
version of who you are
in your words?
- Look, I was a kid who grew
up with two amazing parents.
My dad was a refugee from Hungary
who actually grew up in Queens.
My mom grew up in the Catskill Mountains
and she lost her dad when she was 11
and really made her own
accomplishments after that
and they moved us to a suburb in New York
and I grew up with amazing siblings.
There's five of us.
When I was a teenager,
my parents adopted two more
so there became five of us
and I was kind of a kid who played ball.
I played basketball growing up
and I thought that's what I was gonna do,
I was gonna coach or maybe I'd
become a lawyer, who knows?
I knew I wasn't going to
the NBA. Five foot 11 Jew,
it wasn't adding up.
- Not gonna happen.
- But when I got to college,
I kind of became frustrated
with being broke.
So I started first selling fake ids
and then quickly realized
I was gonna get caught
so I stopped doing that.
I became a party promoter
and became a very big party
promoter in Atlanta, Georgia
at the height of hip hop
growing in Atlanta in like 2000.
- Yeah, some of your
throwback Thursday photos
are so gangster, they just are.
- It's funny like Young Jeezy and I
knew each other
when he was just Young
Jeezy, the drug dealer,
not even a rapper.
- Right.
- And yet he would come to my
parties and we would hang out.
But I kind of came up,
I worked Throw Them Boes for Ludacris,
that was the first person
I worked in the clubs,
this guy Shakir Stewart
put me in the music game
with Chaka Zulu, Ludacris' manager.
And then Jermaine Dupri
asked me to help him out,
I was 20 years old,
became the vice president of So So Def,
dropped out of school, Young Bloods,
Anthony Hamilton--
- You know what?
I didn't know that, you
dropped out of school?
- I dropped out of school my
sophomore year.
- Did your parents shit?
- So for the first semester
of me being dropped out, I--
- Lied?
- Well I lied, I actually
paid for the semester
so they wouldn't send my parents the mail.
And by them getting the mail,
they didn't really know
I was out of school
and then they kept asking me stories
and I'd always be traveling
'cause I was using, at the time, Air Tran,
which was this airline that went under
but it was out of Atlanta.
They had some--
- Did it go under because a plane crashed?
- I don't even know why.
- I think it was, by the way,
I remember Air Tran,
big shout out to Moose, my homie
who was my boy, lived in
Alpharetta after college--
- You Air Tranned?
- Dude, we would go to Vegas for a weekend
and he'd get there for four dollars.
- Well this is the thing,
anyone with a college id,
'cause this is pre-9/11,
so it wasn't even id,
it was just a college id,
could go anywhere on Air Tran
if there was an available
seat for 49 bucks.
- That's what he did.
- And I would fly all the way
around the country working,
building relationships for $49 a ticket
and I would throw my parties
and then throw parties in Miami
and I was traveling all around the country
on Air Tran for $49
and that gave me an
opportunity to get places.
- When you were throwing parties,
this is just me now getting
fun and excited and curious,
there's only two deltas.
On the delta of business
and on the delta of
hooking up and having fun,
what were you at that point?
- Pure business.
- 100?
- 100.
- I kind of thought that's
what you were gonna say,
that's why I asked.
- Yeah, I was 100%.
- I actually fully believe that.
My thing was did I have fun,
was I single, did I meet girls?
Yes.
But never the ones at my parties.
If I was gonna meet women,
it was on the days where
I wasn't throwing parties
and I was going out.
If you were coming to my parties,
I wasn't gonna--
- You were working.
- I was working and I
wasn't getting caught up.
I didn't even drink. Maybe
I'd do a shot here and there
but I was there to make
money and run a business
and I had no interest
and I always used to say,
the guys who were trying to get laid
off of being a party promoter,
they're gonna lose to me
because they're too busy--
- 100,000%.
- They're too busy focusing
on the wrong things.
- [Gary] That's right.
- And we built a massive party business,
we were the highest college
promotion company in the country
revenue-wise
and we expanded all over the place
and then started helping
Jermaine, doing all that
and then when I was 24,
I had all these ideas about social media
'cause Facebook had come
and I had all these ideas
and Jermaine wasn't really
listening to me on them
and I got great advice from my dad
where he said, "Look, as long
as you work for someone else,
"you can give your ideas
"but it's their company.
"If you want to go for it, go for it."
And then Lil' Jon just
produced Yeah for Usher,
he and I were out together and he said,
"Look, I worked for Jermaine
for seven years as an AR.
"Don't take seven years,
"he's a great guy
"but you gotta go after your own."
And long story but I ended up leaving,
not by choice actually,
we'll get into that later,
but it was more me wanting
to leave and not doing it
because I was afraid
and then the universe
corrected that for me.
- [Gary] How?
- Something happened in the office where,
basically me and Jermaine's mom
got into it on something stupid
and the next day I come
in and she had fired me
and Jermaine's like, "Well
just give it two weeks
"and I'll fix it."
And that was enough for me to be like,
this is not the career that I want
and she gave me the out
and now I gotta go for it.
And I started my own
management and record label,
I signed a kid off
MySpace named Asher Roth
and we had a big record
called I Love College--
- He had a devastating loss
this weekend,
he's a big 49ers fan, they lost by one.
And four months after that,
I was online middle of the night
looking at little boys sing
'cause that's how you find success,
you go on the internet in
the middle of the night
and watch little boys singing.
Don't do that, that's a joke.
- But you know what's interesting to me,
and I don't know where I picked this up
through our travels through the years
but there was a part of you,
it's funny and I think of Troy Carter
and things of that nature,
there was definitely a part
of you that was strategic
of like, the hip hop industry
has a lot of vulnerabilities on the talent
and just a million different things
and just raw numbers
of how many albums sell.
You weren't just doing
that for kicks and giggles,
there was a thought process
of a pop star of
and you also, Scooter, is this right?
I remember this vividly
from literally I think our first dinner
like a decade ago,
didn't you try to put together a boy band
at some point as well?
- Well I tried to find
holes in the marketplace
and what I did was try,
not a boy band,
I put together a group and it failed.
- Didn't they live in
your house or something?
- They lived in my house.
They ended up robbing
the apartment complex
that I put them in.
It was like I tried a
couple different things.
I put together another group
and then they actually went
to jail for bank robbery
that I didn't know they
were robbing federal banks,
that's a real thing,
I got investigated by the
FBI, it was pretty wild but--
- Did all those experience take you to,
I need like a nine year old child?
- No, what it took me
to was someone saying
you are trying to sign
everything that you think we want
instead of what you want.
- Interesting.
- And this guy, Jerry Smoking B,
who at the time was the program director
of Hot97 in Atlanta,
he said, "You're really talented,
"stop trying to sign everything
"that you think we want.
"Sign what you want and
what you think is good."
And I looked in the
marketplace and I said,
"What's the opening?"
And with Asher I was like,
at the time Eminem was the
only white rapper and I said,
here's this kid who can really spit
but also isn't trying
to be anything he isn't
and there's a lot of kids
who go to hip hop shows
who look like him and relate to him
and that's why I did that.
And with Justin, I said--
- Who wrote the college song?
- He did.
And with Justin,
I looked at it and I said,
one, Chaka Zulu,
Ludacris' manager he said,
"You're lucky if you gt one
big star your whole career
"or one breakthrough.
"People can live off that forever."
I said, "Well, I'm gonna
break two right away
"if that's the case."
And with Justin I said,
I'm a big Michael Jackson fan
and Michael used to sing
these angelic love songs
in the Jackson 5
and his voice reminded
you of when you were a kid
before you were jaded by love.
So you believe in the love story.
And when I saw Justin, I was like,
this is the kid I've been looking for
and I found him, brought
him in and signed Justin.
- Scooter, with no bullshit,
I'm just dying to know,
you may not remember,
but I'm dying to know this
'cause I don't know it,
how many views was he getting
on his YouTube--
- 60,000.
- About 60,000
which was at the time a lot
but nothing compared to what it is now.
- It was like, okay, some
people are paying attention
but at the time,
people gave a fuck if you had a million.
A million was the breakthrough.
And it was our 20th video where
we got our first a million
but all the videos we had
accumulated up until that
suddenly became--
- How many videos did he have
that you were able to look at?
- Four, four to six I think.
- And you emailed him through YouTube?
- Well I tried, I tried everything
but his mom had a different
last name than him
and I tried everything
and then I Googled the companies
in the back of the image
and I found out they
were a part of Ontario
and I called every school board
in that part of Ontario until I found him
and then his mom called to get rid of me
'cause she thought I was a stalker
and after 45 minutes of speaking to me
she agreed to get on the first plane ride
either of them had ever been on.
And we've been together ever since.
- I love it.
It's insane.
Okay, cool, so that's the nutshell, right?
- That's the origin
and then we went on and things went well
and I really focused
on that for four years
and then someone who I
respected took a shot at me
and said, "Oh, he's good
but he only has that."
And I got pissed so I said,
okay, well I'm gonna sign things
that I can break quickly.
So I signed The Wanted
with "Glad You Came",
I signed "Gangnam Style",
I signed Carly Rae Jepsen
with "Call Me Maybe".
- By the way, my most fun story that I,
Scooter doesn't know this,
I went over to Scooter's house in LA
just on a friend visit
and I was just there for a night
flying back the next
morning and texted him,
he's like, "Come over."
I came over
and he's like, "Hey man, I want
you to listen to this song."
And I'm not from the music industry,
that's not my norm,
Boyd and I do some fun
stuff in hip hop these days
but like this might be
the third time in my life
I ever heard a song before anybody else
and he plays "Call Me Maybe" and I'm like,
"Man, that's super fucking catchy."
But I thought I was just doing that
because I don't even know
but to watch that, man that is so fun,
I did it with start
ups, I do it with wine,
I do it with other things but
music is so deeply cultural
and that was such a smash hit song,
that was a the song of the year,
to like hear it in your
backyard that night
and then two months later hear it
every single place ever,
that's a fun part of your game.
- Mmhmm.
- Justin heard her on the radio in Canada,
what was it again?
his friend told him,
it was number 36 on the Canadian chart
and then he came back
and played it and I said,
"This is really good."
And I looked into it
and the labels in the US had passed
and I said, oh this is not, this is,
so I went in and I signed it
for the world wide outside of Canada,
and we ended up selling 26
million copies or something.
And then "Gangnam Style" and then--
- That was the best.
- And then we signed
Ariana and Martin Garrix
and we just kept going
and then we bought other
management companies
and we just expanded
and I'm always in this mentality,
you and I have talked about it,
that out of everything that's happened
from TV to film,
all these different things,
I just assume it's gonna
end tomorrow at all times.
- So you're squeezing the fuck out of it?
- Not even squeezing the fuck out of it,
just never letting it be overwhelming
in a way of thinking I did it.
We can argue about this,
I actually don't know
how you feel about this,
I just think anyone who says
that luck doesn't play a part
in their success is naive.
- I think it's completely predicated
on how you define luck.
I think so much is not in my control
and so that's how I think about it,
luck is an interesting word.
I think the way one uses it
but much like the person said,
"He's good but he's only got one thing."
To me, I was traded for wheat.
I was born in the Soviet Union
during the height of the Cold War
and nobody in my country,
let's get it very simple here,
nobody in my country had left
that country for 40 years.
You couldn't leave.
They didn't let you leave,
that's what the Soviet Union was,
and I got to leave as
a three year old baby
because 400,000 Jews got traded for wheat
because Russia needed some wheat
and America and Israel teamed up.
To me that is the most lucky thing
but to me, it all depends
on how you look at the,
most of our lives,
you could get hit by a truck tomorrow.
- No 100%
but I look at it as a fact of like
I think if you acknowledge that luck,
you don't lose it.
- See I think where you're going
and I agree with you completely is like
getting high on your own--
- You can't get high on your own supply.
- Couldn't believe it more,
that's exactly where I was going.
Look, I think the thing you
and I will both agree with
because I know your family
well enough to know this,
we are disproportionately,
you started your, I'm the
product of two wonderful parents
is your opening line.
Everybody on my team here watching
I'm sure took note of that
because that's all I talk about,
I'm the product of my parents
in such a big way.
- I don't think
the American dream,
I think as we're kids,
we're told about this American dream
and I think people think it's
you come here and you live it.
I don't think that's what it
is. I think the American dream
is you come here and you
give your kids an opportunity
to live it.
I mean your parents came here,
you're living the American dream.
My parents came here,
I'm living the American dream.
And that is a reflection
of the sacrifices made my them
to give us that opportunity.
- And then obviously the way
we think about our grandparents
and things of that,
it gets so intense.
Look, I think where you're
going really matters
which is literally,
I genuinely believe this,
it's an interesting conversation,
for me the biggest thing though
is I just don't think
anything I did yesterday
matters anymore.
I really am big on you're only
as good as your last at bat
and I'm glad that I
have some sort of resume
but if I start fucking up
tomorrow, it gets washed.
- Okay, so this is where
it's gonna get fun for people
because I'm gonna push you on that.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- I think where we're always
gonna end up as agreeing
but I just want to push you on that--
- [Gary] No go ahead, go ahead.
- So I agree with you,
especially in this world
that the judgment on us
is you're only as good
as your last at bat.
And I think to remain successful,
you have to have that mentality
otherwise you get complacent
and complacency kills.
But the other side of that
is if you're constantly
trying to outdo and outdo
and outdo yourself,
and you don't acknowledge yesterday,
you can go into a very, very dark place
and feel like you're not enough ever.
- You know, it's interesting,
this is gonna be super,
you're right, this is gonna be fun,
I don't know if I've ever thought
about outdoing myself.
I think I just love it so much
that I want to be able
to have the permission
to continue to play--
- You're a very unique soul
and I think, that's the truth,
because you,
and we can get into whether you
deal with depression or not,
I don't know, but I think
a lot of people I've met,
they get into this place,
even with "Gangnam Style" right?
I remember when I did that,
here I am, I'm taking this guy,
who is my brother now,
me and him, me and Psy have this thing,
we joke around, we actually
say this to each other,
instead of just saying I love you,
we say love you, fuck you,
that's a joke,
it's a joke between us.
- Where is he living right now?
- He lives in Korea
and he goes back and forth to Beijing
and he does a bunch of stuff
between the two but Psy's great
but the difference is is like
Psy was like, "I have to do it again,
"I have to do it again." People were like,
"oh that was good but
can you do it again?"
Actually, Gentlemen went number three,
which was the next one
but the funny thing is
I never sought out to do it again.
I had a slightly overweight Korean man
dancing and singing in
Korean, fully in Korean,
and he's in his 40s
and he's coming to the United States.
I wanted to get that to be
number one in the United States
and around the world.
We did that.
It stayed there for multiple weeks.
That was the impossible
and that's what people do,
you achieve the impossible and they go,
"Oh that was cool but can you do this?"
And I think if you start
to get in that mold
of the expectations of
others and what they want,
you miss the point that you
already achieved greatness
and you have to live in that too.
So I understand what you're saying,
I think the problem with me and Gary
is we always say the same thing
but we say it in
completely different ways.
- Look, I only think I admire you so much
because of our similarities
'cause I love myself so much.
- You play a large part in how
I got back in shape though.
I actually wanted to give you love to that
because I'm gonna live years longer
for my boys and my daughter because of you
because I watched Gary hire a trainer 24/7
and I was like, you know what,
I'm in a place financially
where I can do that.
- [Gary] And it makes so much sense.
- And I need to kickstart myself.
So I hired a trainer
to stay with me for 30 straight days
day in and day out.
- Dude, there was some photo
you posted on Instagram
where I was like, fuck,
you got into shape quickly
and when you do the right things
but man you had some real
fucking muscles in one photo.
I was like, fuck that's a lot of muscles.
- You know what, I got Irv's DNA.
My dad is 64, has a six pack,
he's like 200 pounds, six foot two,
he's a big dude
and I got his DNA
so I was able to,
my friend Eugene,
who I had Rumble with,
he was giving me shit,
he was like, "I worked out like you,
"why is this not happening?"
And I was like, I have friends who
it doesn't happen for me the
way it happened for them.
- I was excited to see you guys do,
you guys went into a pretty
significant partnership, right?
'Cause he's really,
I like him a lot.
- He's a great guy
and I'm really excited for--
- Did you know him in the catch days
and even before that, the promoter days?
- [Scooter] Yeah.
- So you've known him a long time?
- 10 June.
- Scooter, what is it,
let me go completely left field
on the back of that Eugene comment,
you and I are different in one way,
you have been in the,
you've grown up in the scene,
and grew in the scene
meaning I did something very weird,
I literally worked in a
liquor store in New Jersey,
never went to Manhattan,
LA, Atlanta, anywhere,
literally for 14, until I
was like 34, 35 years old.
I've been fascinated with,
I keep bringing up these
throwback kind of things
because much like Eugene as well,
I was like oh,
not that I envy, I was like
oh, it would've been cool
to come up with all these people
and like see everybody,
I came out of left field kind
of in a lot of ways into it.
What does it feel like to,
how do you look at things
like Eugene and others,
when you see a lot of people
that you came up with,
some accelerated, some fell off,
some did better than you
thought in your own fun game,
what does it feel like
to be part of a scene and
culture for two decades
but still be so young
where you know there's another
three, four, five chapters?
I'm sure you look at some of your friends
who are 38 and say, "Wow,
she's gonna be the governor
"of California one day,
"that one's gonna be this,"
how does it feel to be
part of the zeitgeist,
that's the way I would put it?
- Look, it's cool
'cause there's history with certain people
and you're rooting for each other
and you kind of come up
and there's a respect 'cause you know--
- They grinded.
- You know that they grinded--
- That's what I like
- And you know the mentality,
like Eugene, like me,
has never been someone to
party at his own parties.
He was a worker from day one
and a Russian immigrant
who made it happen
and came to the city
and saw the opportunity
and grinded it out.
- Wait, he was like in Ohio
or something like that?
- No, he was just coming into the city.
- But do you know where he was,
okay, go ahead.
- I think he grew up around here.
- Got it.
- And I think for me,
that's really great
but at the same time,
I also get upset when I see
certain people from that scene
who, they find resentment in that
and I just--
- [Gary] Because they
didn't make it as big
and they were ahead of other people?
- Sometimes it's they were ahead,
they didn't make it as big.
Other times they are making it big
but they've made the mistake
of thinking that, and I see
it with people I've known,
see it with people that I don't know,
they make the mistake
of thinking success is
some kind of zero sum game.
- Yeah, I'm blown away
by people's inability
to understand the abundance.
I'm shocked by that.
- Well I've never
understood it because I--
- It's not practical.
- It's not practical
and it think the way I've
figured out how to explain it
makes it easier for people to understand,
because we grew up in a world
where we think that if I'm winning,
someone else should be losing
or if I'm losing, someone else is winning
and that's why people get into that mode
and what I like to explain is,
I call it the vacation theory
where if I'm successful
and none of my friends are successful,
I have to pay for them to
go on vacation with me.
I don't want to pay for your vacation.
My goal in life is to
have all of my friends
become successful
so that they also can
pay for the nice vacation
and it isn't all on me financially.
So if you think of it that way,
because I think a lot of people,
they kind of look into it,
like I want to be the one who makes it.
No you want everyone to make
it and the other thing I'll say
is whenever I talk to powerful people,
and I had the pleasure today of sitting
with a mentor of mine today,
who's had an incredible career,
he's one of my favorite
people in the world,
and when he talks about
other super powerful people,
he talks about 30, 40, 50 years of history
and what I think the
beautiful part about that is
people make this this idea
that I gotta get to this person.
They think they gotta get to you.
They think they gotta get to me.
You want to know who you gotta get to?
They're sitting next to
you in the living room
dreaming just like you.
They are your peers.
If you come up,
anyone who's powerful,
their network is more
powerful than their money.
They can say, "Oh, who do you need?
"I've known him for 20 years,
let me make a phone call."
It's coming up, that grind.
Me and Eugene, we went
into this business together
because we knew each other from the grind.
I can call, when I needed Ludacris on Baby
back in he day for Justin's first single
that would give him some credibility,
it was because Ludacris and I came up
with Throw Them Bows in a night club.
So for me, it's not about the
person you aspire to know.
You should go to them for stories,
get some wisdom.
But if you want to know who
you need to network with,
network with your peers
and help each other rise up
and that's where power comes from.
- Scooter, let me ask you a question.
What do you think you're
dramatically better at,
as a dude, as human,
what do you think you're
way better at today
than even just five years ago?
- Watching the Jets lose.
I'm much better at it now--
- We're very good at that.
On a serious note--
- Than I was five years ago.
- Because what I think is
super interesting about my,
I don't even know why,
I'm intuitively asking this
because again listen,
we're so busy,
we don't get to spend
that much time together.
- I know the answer.
- You know the answer
to the question?
- I know the answer
'cause I had to go to a
very dark place to find it.
- Tell me 'cause I'm really curious.
- So you know a lot
about me and my family.
So two years ago I lost one
of the most important people
in my life which was my grandmother,
and she was one of the
most special human beings
anyone's ever met,
and everyone who knew her loved her
and she was an Auschwitz
Holocaust survivor
so she saw the worst of humanity
but literally was the light
in every room she went into
and everyone called her Ma.
When she passed away,
my brother, 11 hours later had twins,
and nine days later I had my second son.
So now I got a wife with a 21
month old baby and a newborn,
she's breast feeding,
I got a dad who's broken
because both his parents are gone
and I'm trying to be the
rock for the whole family
and I didn't have time for grieving.
So I started going into a depression
which I wasn't used to.
I had gone to different
dark places in the past
but I couldn't shake this one,
I couldn't sleep it off,
I couldn't get away from it.
And I started to get even more depressed
because no one was
asking me if I was okay.
Because I'd been the rock
for all of my friends and
my family my entire life,
I'm always okay,
I'm always the mature one,
I have fun, I go crazy
but I was always the one
that you didn't have to worry about.
And I'm always the one
who goes and fixes
everyone else's problem.
And finally a friend of mine
I opened up to and he said,
"You need to talk to
your wife about it too."
And I went and talked to my wife
and I expected her to be like,
"Baby, we can get through anything."
And instead she looked
and me and she goes,
"You can always talk to me
about anything, I love you
"but this is your fault."
- Yeah, you made the bed.
I'm that person in my life.
I get it.
- And I said what are you
talking about?
She goes, "You always fix
everyone else's problems
"but you don't stay long enough
"to let them know your
insecurities, your vulnerabilities,
"and who you are.
"So you think you're
connected to all these people
"but they don't feel connected to you.
"They just trust you can help 'em out."
And I decided as a New Year's resolution
that I would take time to engage
and show people who I was
so that they could be
there for me in dark times.
And I am much better about that now,
taking time out of my busy schedule
to say, stop and speak to
people and engage with them
and let them know that I've
been through those moments.
And my life is more fulfilling now,
I have more genuine friendships now
that I didn't even know weren't genuine
and that's actually why
I even take the time
to do stuff like this
because I want to get
that message out there,
I want people to know
vulnerability is strength.
I think a lot of people,
they think they gotta
be so tough all the time
because it's weak if
you show you're scared.
And that's not weakness.
- You know what's funny?
Did you think it was weakness or,
I'm asking you this because this is where
we have a huge similarity,
for me, it comes so natural.
- To help people?
- Yeah.
- No 100%.
- I have so much optimism and happiness
and emotional strength
that whether it's a subconscious guilt,
whether it just appeases me,
whether it's control,
like I know I do a lot
of things emotionally
because it's the leverage.
I can feel it in me if
I'm self-evaluating.
There's an abundance of
emotional strength that--
- Which we get from our parents.
- 100,00%.
- 100%.
- Like the reason I do it
is 'cause I have it to give
and when I'm surrounded by
family members, business people,
friends, acquaintances,
I want to be there, I want to do it.
Boyd's in the room right now,
I had so much fun on a late Friday night
calling him at 11:30 PM
and giving him a piece of advice,
that made me happy
because I had it to give
but to your point,
there's no question,
in the back of my mind,
it's funny that you gave that answer.
I had the great misfortune
of losing all my
grandparents except for one
before I was born.
So basically the only fucking thing
I give a fuck about is
like 11 or 12 people
and as long as they're
healthy and here, I'm good.
It's interesting,
I have still, I'm 42
years old, soon to be 43,
I'm widely aware that in my
uniqueness of always being happy
that the domino that's most vulnerable
is something happening
to one of those eight or nine, 10 people.
And I sit here at 43 and I'm like,
for all the who I am
and I'm a wild character
and I'm a unique dude,
I'm like yeah, but guess what?
The kryptonite hasn't happened.
My mom isn't terminally ill,
I have kids,
I mean the kids one,
if you want to talk about,
when you're a family guy or gal,
you always talk about the greatest,
and especially like in
our culture I think,
the greatest fear ever
is like losing a child.
Like I couldn't even like,
you want to talk about
like knocking on wood,
I'm just like, well that put me into,
am I gonna be like Luke Skywalker
in like the new movies
and go into a cave forever?
- I think I probably would.
- Because I don't think that
wouldn't be inappropriate.
- Let me ask you this.
I want to test this.
And I don't know what's gonna happen.
He called you the other
night at 11:30 and be honest.
- [Gary] Yeah be honest and Boyd will be.
- Boyd, he obviously knows you
and can help you out
but do you honestly feel you know him?
- And why?
- But has he opened up to you
about his fears and stuff?
- So my thing is,
I thought my friends would say,
yeah, I know him
but when I needed help,
they didn't even know that was something
that made sense.
- Scooter can I ask
you a great question,
these is super fun,
this is super interesting content,
did you even know what it felt like,
it's cool, I could tell Boyd,
for example, and Boyd might be,
the only thing I ever talk
about from a fear standpoint
is losing or the health and
wellbeing of everyone else.
Do you think that you would've even known
that you were capable of going
to that place consistently?
It's funny,
you said something,
dude, I'm so weirded out by some of our,
again, I think I want the
audience to know this,
Scooter and I have had
this incredibly interesting relationship,
I compare it in a funny way,
I've never said this to him,
of like relationships I
have with my family members
who I take most for granted
'cause we're almost playing on
the same mental wave length.
You would probably be stunned
how little time Scooter and I
have actually spent together
over the last decade
'cause it's just the way we roll
but there is this deep kinship.
The fact that you said sleep it off,
it is insane to me that basically
when the worst business things
or life things that have
happened to me outside,
which I would deem as not that--
- You've got to shut this off,
the only way to sleep it off.
- I just go to sleep
and the next morning I'm like, let's win.
I remember when I lost,
this is a business thing,
we lost the ability to ship to Texas
which was crippling for Wine Library
and we were the only company
that was picked on by FedEx
to not ship to Texas
and it was lot of money,
it was four million dollars,
we were a small business,
and like literally it was
like, this is dangerous shit.
I went home at 3:30 in the afternoon,
went to sleep, woke up the next day
and just started chopping
wood and like fixed it.
- That's who I am.
- And I kind of picked up on that
'cause it was very subtle
the way you said it.
So I understand, I don't know if,
let me ask you a question,
have you ever been able to sustain
being depressed or upset?
For how long prior to Ma?
Yeah, prior to Ma?
- Prior to Ma, there
might be a couple days
of being in your own
head and stuff like that.
- So to me, I've never been able
to be in a full 24 hour cycle
of true depress--
- No 100%
like it kind of goes back and forth.
When that happened,
it went really, really bad
and what was shocking
wasn't the depression.
What was shocking was he says he knows you
but because he's never seen you like that,
the shocking part was
that people didn't know
to ask me if I was okay,
they didn't know to say,
they didn't even comprehend the idea
that I could be broken.
- I get it, man, brother,
I fucking get it.
- And
when I admitted that,
I had to ask myself why is that?
And that was on me,
that's what my wife taught me.
- [Gary] She's 100% right.
- And I didn't express my fears,
I didn't express my vulnerabilities,
they didn't know what to look for.
They didn't know to be there
and I feel like a lot of people,
like I was like, well of
course they should know,
I've been so, I've been in
really important moments
in these people's lives,
I've been there for so
many different people
but I realized,
I never took the time to say,
because I'm like you,
I'm energy, I'm gone,
I'm this that, I fixed
it, time to go back,
next thing you know, Superman,
I can hear everything
going on, let's go and--
- [Gary] Omnipresent.
- And the bottom line is
what I had to teach myself
which I'm better at,
going back to your original
question is to say,
yes, I could do 40 more
things today but I'm not.
I'm gonna stay right here
and I'm gonna get deep with this person
and I'm going to engage in
a way I normally don't do.
- [Gary] Interesting, I fully understand.
- And that is something
that has made me happier
because it actually hasn't slowed down
any of my success,
it hasn't slowed down any of my progress
and what it has done
is made me go with more
joy into the next day,
more ready to fight
because I feel like I had
a genuine moment that day
that I didn't even realize I was missing
two or three years before.
- Yeah 'cause the speed
in which you're going,
it's a width game, not a depth game.
Yeah man, I super get it,
I super understood that.
Andy, you happy with some questions?
I'm sure people want to do some questions.
Let's do a quick question
and we'll keep bouncing
'cause I have some other contemporary q,
we've gone deep here a little
bit which I appreciate.
No, it's super interesting.
I super get it.
It's funny, I'm sitting here,
a lot of the vulnerabilities
that I've created
in the two companies that I run,
Wine Library and Vayner,
the vulnerabilities are
I created entitlement
because I put so much on me.
- I have the same thing.
My staff is about to hear this
so they're gonna never
play ping pong again
but I've been getting very frustrated,
we have a ping pong table
in the middle of the office
and I keep seeing all the
young people playing ping pong
and I'm like, what the, how
are you able to play ping pong
if I'm killing myself?
And I always had this
rule where I was like,
if you can't say you work harder than me,
you can't complain
and no one ever fucking complains
except Allison who
probably is the only person
who works harder than me,
she's been with me for a decade,
and Allison had a child
and was on email two hours later
and I was like, "Allison, get off email."
And she goes, "It's boring here."
She is an animal.
- [Gary] I love Allison already.
- I can't understand,
especially when you're that age--
- [Maxson] Hello?
- Why you
wouldn't grind 24/7?
- Who's this?
What's that?
- Maxson.
- Max?
- [Maxson] Yeah, Max works Gary.
- Maxson works too brother, Maxson,
you're on with Scooter Braun, how are you?
- [Maxson] Oh my God,
I'm good, how are you?
- Good, what's your question?
- [Maxon] Yeah, I was
coming with a question.
My brother, he is an EDM producer,
he's been doing it for
about four or five years
and I help him sometimes
and my question is is that
he does a lot of local shows,
he lives down in New Mexico
and I live in Vermont
so we do mostly FaceTime
but he does a lot of--
- First of all, hold on,
real quick Maxson, I'm just
very excited about this,
the fact that you're in Vermont
and he's in New Mexico
is just the greatest part
of this story
'cause I don't know how
many people have the Mexico,
New Mexico, Vermont relationship.
I think it's rare.
I think there's a very
small amount of people
that the connection is
Vermont and New Mexico
and I think you need to
think about how rare that is
and maybe monetize it.
- Okay.
- Alright, keep going.
- [Maxson] It's a rare combo.
- Very.
- [Maxson] Yeah so he
does a lot of local shows
and he's on SoundCloud
but I guess my thought
is is that obviously
he'll send out his songs to
different independent labels
and he's had some singles with it
for like one time releases.
What's some advice maybe you
would offer Scooter or Gary
on what he can maybe do to get attention
for different A&R contacts
or people at labels
beyond social media?
I mean social media's very
important, I know that,
but just some other ideas.
- And Maxson, real quick
before Scooter answers
is the goal to get signed?
I think the goal is the
most important question.
- [Maxson] Yeah, definitely the
goal would be to get signed.
He's a senior at college now
and he has a friend who's
been doing it with him
since high school
and he's a junior.
I know he's working contacts,
he's setting up in Amsterdam
so he's been working with
different leads in there too.
- Okay, I'm ready to answer buddy.
- [Maxson] Okay yeah.
- I disagree with your goal
and it's against me being
able to sign artists
but I just think with this
equalizer we call the internet
and the fact that you now have Spotify
saying they'll do direct
deals with artists
and we have this platform,
especially in a genre like EDM
where albums are very insignificant
and it's all about singles
and mostly touring,
I don't know why you
would want to get signed.
I think what you should be doing
is focusing on building a fan base,
not worrying about getting to an executive
and pushing out the
music through SoundCloud,
pushing the music as
far as you possibly can
and building up a base,
building up a proper brand for yourself
and let the labels chase you,
let the A&R's chase you,
you shouldn't be chasing them,
especially in a time where it's
never been more advantageous
to be independent
with the resources at your fingertips.
I just think you guys are
focused on the wrong thing
and that's probably why you
haven't found success yet.
I think once you guys--
- So sort of, oh go ahead,
I'm sorry.
- No, I just think once you focus
on building the brand properly
and just getting to the consumer
and getting to the fans,
I think you'll start to
see success coming your way
and not worrying about how do we get
the attention of some A&R.
- [Maxson] Okay, so sort of you build it,
they'll come, kind of?
- These guys are all scared
trying to hold on to their jobs
and they're not interested in taking risks
like they used to.
They're just trying to chase the momentum.
So the other thing is,
I think once you get the momentum,
you won't be calling Gary Vee
or myself back and saying,
"Hey, which deal do we take?"
You'll be saying, "I don't
really want to take a deal,
"I like my economics
better now on my own."
- [Maxson] Yeah, I
definitely can see that.
- Maxson, I want to
paint a picture for you.
You literally just called and said,
"Yo, what kind of VHS video
store should I open up?
"I want to build the next Blockbuster."
Literally in the face of Netflix
and Hulu and Amazon Prime
and the golden era of OTT.
That is literally no joke in my opinion
what it's like to be thinking
about I disproportionately am passionate
about getting signed
in the moment of the dist,
I literally would rather
you have your brother's song
be distributed in the background
of a vlogger that's
crushing YouTube right now
than you getting discovered.
- Can I also add to this to just tell you,
I think a lot of artists,
DJs, they want to get to me
because of my career.
I would even say at 37,
I'm afraid I'm becoming a dinosaur.
Technology has disrupted
music so many times
and the resources are so there.
I got kids now,
I got 100 different businesses.
The way I built an artist
was because that artist
was 24/7 my sole purpose
and I think that the resources I have now
can take an artist from stage A to G,
we'll skip all the other letters
because I have the network
but I can't do it without
someone getting to step A
and step A is really
breaking it themselves
and having that passion.
And if you guys are talking about this
and you're calling in from
Vermont when he's in New Mexico,
it means that you got a lot
of passion for your brother
and I would use that passion
'cause you don't have to be next to him.
When I was doing Justin,
he was in Canada half the time
and I was doing it from Atlanta.
The resources are there for you.
Give it to the people,
build it with them,
and then you'll be having a
very, very different discussion
the next time you call.
- [Maxson] Okay, I
definitely respect that.
- Maxson, listen, I'm telling you this
and this is gonna help a lot of people,
the biggest vulnerability
I see across the board
in everything, in culture, business, life
is people are putting
something on a pedestal
that was yesterday
without understanding what's
gonna happen tomorrow.
This has happened already.
The leverage has swung to the artist
because distribution is
controlled by the internet.
Scooter's giving you tremendous advice
in lieu of what he
actually does of a living
in the same way that I
tell big brands every day
don't hire agencies,
even though that's what I do for a living.
And the reason we're doing that
is because first,
we create other
opportunities for ourselves
because we're always hedging
against the vulnerability
of our current state
but second because historically correct
is always going to be the value prop.
There is absolutely no reason
to pander to getting signed.
You need to get the audience to love you,
you need to get the music
distributed and out there.
- And by the way, if this
was 20, 30 years ago,
you'd be saying, how do
I get it distributed?
I'm pretty sure you know how to do that
on a worldwide level.
- [Maxson] Yeah, no, that's
definitely something we do.
He has had some good runoff stuff.
I had a song that went like 50,000 plays
so progress.
- But the answer is more,
the thing I tell, having Boyd in the room,
I meet with a lot of
emerging hip hop artists
'cause I like it, Boyd likes it, it's fun
but I always tell them
more fucking music, please.
You're one fucking song away.
The preciousness, the overproducing,
go ahead Scooter.
- Here's what I'll say also--
- [Maxson] I did like the
video you did with Kyle Gary.
- Yeah and that was one
of the early ones right
and I just don't understand
how people don't understand
an unbelievable part of this is more.
- I think it's more
and I also think if you're, I
think part of your question,
'cause I want to give
you a proper answer also,
you're saying, how do I
network with these people?
Let's talk about who
you should network with.
- [Maxson] Okay, that's great.
- You said you have
50,000 plays on Spotify.
- [Maxson] For one of the songs yeah.
- Listen, figure out who
runs playlists on Spotify
for the genre you're in
and do whatever the fuck it
takes to get to that person
and make them believe
in what you believe in
and that's who you should be focused on.
That's who the label is gonna call,
focus on that person.
- 100%.
- [Maxson] Wow, okay that's smart.
- Of course it's smart,
who the fuck do you
think you're talking to,
fucking Scooter Braun baby?
- [Maxson] This is true.
- Awesome man, good luck.
Alright, let's go to the next question.
That's exactly right,
I was working on something fun,
I never got to tell you about
it because something happened
but nonetheless, very simply,
I knew more about rap caviar in 48 seconds
than coming from zero
because it's just not complicated.
I think the thing that you understand,
the thing that I definitely understand,
it's what Vince McMahon understands,
it's what Walt Disney understands,
understanding where the
consumer's attention is
and how that's controlled is everything.
Who's this?
- [Andy] Jefferson.
- Jefferson, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
you're on the #AskGaryVee
Show with Scooter Braun.
- [Jefferson] Wow, this is great.
- Listen, I can tell in your
voice how pumped you are,
I totally get it.
- Jefferson, I just want to let you know,
Jefferson, this is great for me too.
- [Jefferson] Wow alright.
- Jefferson, real quick
before you go any further,
this is a very inside joke for Jets fans,
you literally sound like Jeff Fisher
calling the Jets game yesterday
which was pretty classic so nonetheless,
Jefferson, what's your question?
- [Jefferson] So my question is
I came from a different country,
just like you, you know.
- Which country?
- [Jefferson] Guatemala.
- Very nice, keep going
which by the way, I apologize
but I have to say it,
what's so amazing about
you calling from Guatemala
is we referenced earlier in this podcast
I sit on Pencils of Promise's board
and one of the core countries
that we build schools in
is in Guatemala
so big shout out to Pop, keep going.
- [Jefferson] Thank you.
So in high school,
after graduation, I really
wanted to go to school
but after that I saw things
are changing, social media,
so one of your videos popped up
and said that get rid of the people
that don't really help you.
So I did
and now I don't get invited
out to Friday night bars,
Saturday night bars and stuff like that.
- What did you think was gonna happen
when you told your friends
go fuck themselves?
- [Jefferson] So that's
perfectly fine with me
because just like you,
I'm a big family guy.
- Okay.
- [Jefferson] So my question is now
is how do I find--
- Like minded people?
- [Jefferson] Those friends
that I can work with.
- Yep.
So let me ask you a question,
what do you want to do for a living
or what are some of your interests?
- [Jefferson] Okay, so
my dad is a contractor.
So what I did with him was
that we build an LLC company.
- Okay.
- [Jefferson] Okay.
So my dream is to build
him his dream house.
- That's amazing brother.
- [Jefferson] At the end, you know?
- Can I ask you a question?
Do you want to be in
the contracting business
or is that just a dream?
What is the goal for you
in building a business?
What do you want to do?
I know the goal is to
build your dad a house
but how do you want to get there?
What is the business you want to create?
- [Jefferson] Okay, so I found
what we're really good at
and my dad does a lot of custom works
and his customer service is amazing,
not like any other
contracted business there.
I want to help him become bigger
for him to hire other people.
- And you want to do that
by bringing marketing to the business
or being another pair of
hands that can do craft?
How were you thinking about that?
- [Jefferson] So I got into social media
on Facebook advertisement,
Instagram advertisement
and I did get some clients from there
but I want to know how we can find,
how I personally can find friends
that can push me to be better?
Because I would always ask
somebody to come with me
and to learn more things
but at the end of the day,
they always like cancel on me.
- I totally understand.
- Look, I'm trying to
understand the question.
So I'm gonna answer it
a couple different ways.
I don't know if it'll
be helpful but I'll try.
- [Jefferson] Yeah.
- Number one, I can tell you
from my party promoter days,
90% of the people that were in the club
with me 10 years ago are still there.
So when you're talking
about Friday night bars
and this, that and the other,
no life has been changed
on Friday night drinking.
If you're young and ambitious,
it's good to live life and have fun
but I wouldn't worry about that
as the letdown and anything
that's gonna stop you.
So just disregard that
because those people aren't
gonna be grinding like you.
As far as finding like minded people,
I don't know your personality
well enough to see who
you're gonna gel with.
What I can tell you is I would do research
on larger companies that
you admire in your space.
Look at these companies that have taken,
find people who took contracting companies
and built them into larger
real estate holdings
and people who ended up
going from contracting houses
to building out commercial real
estate and different things.
There are people who literally
started off in that business
and then ended up owning
huge amount of real estate themselves
and building very big businesses
and sometimes they're doing
that in different ways.
So what I would say is
start doing those research,
find those people, create mentors
and they might introduce
you to someone else your age
and say, "Hey, someone else called me,
"there's another like minded
person you should meet."
I remember years ago I went
and met someone at a record label
and he said, "There's
someone you should meet
"and his name's Adam Granite,
"he's a young guy,
"he's become like a GM over here."
And now Adam and I have
stayed friends all this time
and Adam is now the new,
he's one of the top international
guys at Universal Music
and we work hand in hand
and we've had a friendship
since I was 19 years old.
- Can I ask you a quick
question, Jefferson?
Are you looking for these friends
because you want to get value out of them
in the business world
or because you want some
people to hang out with
on a Saturday night who are pushing you?
And I think both matter,
I'm just curious what you're looking for?
- [Jefferson] Yeah because I just want
somebody to be there to help me as well
if I have any questions.
So basically--
- Honestly the reason I asked you
and even the way you answered,
I was getting that vibe.
I'm wondering if,
there's a very big difference
between finding mentors
and finding friends who are ambitious.
- I would say Tinder or Bumble.
- [Jefferson] Got it.
- But do you see what I mean?
I think you might be asking
for mentorship not friendship
which is very okay,
I'm just, I got that sense
and is that true or not?
- [Jefferson] That's true.
- Okay, so to me, couple things,
and I want to move on,
you're 18, so the biggest fear I have
even in this series of
questions and energy
is I promise you one thing
Scooter and I will agree on
is patience matters man.
This is a marathon.
We ate so much fucking shit.
It's so, not frustrating,
because I want everybody to win,
but the amount of people
that are gonna lose
that thought it happened overnight for us
without understanding
the sheer amount of out,
one thing I also know about Scooter
and I'm sure this is how he was
'cause I know him these days,
I'm sure this was even more
because we were both
younger for that reason,
sheer hours of output,
I'm like 84.
- I mean look, I'll speak to that
and Gary just triggered something in me.
So I still remember vividly
going home in my 20s and my dad saying,
"I want to talk to you. "I
think you're working too hard,
"you're missing out on stuff."
And I looked at him and I said,
"Dad, I'm trying to do something
no one's ever done before
"so I'm not in that mode of joy yet,
"I'm in the mode of grind."
And I had to make certain sacrifices
to get to where I was.
That being said,
when Gary was talking,
I was also thinking about
there's this big misconception
about success because
of stories like Gary's,
stories like mine,
stories like Mark Zuckerberg
and people think it just
happens at a young age
and it goes for you in your 30s
and the truth is the average entrepreneur
doesn't even find the business
that makes them successful
till they're 39 years old
and I just read another
article that got put out
that the average entrepreneur
who has a successful business in tech
is 47 when they start.
So there's this misconception
it's all these young people
and it's just not the truth.
- And don't forget brother,
the other thing that
I'm scared shitless of
is it's been a decade of good economy.
So you've got all these
Instagram entrepreneurs
that are gonna get blown the fuck out
when the economy hits the fan
and people are overleveraged,
trying to act like tough guys and gals
and they're gonna lose.
And so there's so many layers to this.
Your biggest advantage--
- [Scooter] Is you're 18.
- Bingo.
I'm scared to, I'm so curious,
I say this a lot Scooter
and take life, you have such
a great family thing going on,
professionally,
would you trade everything
you've got right now
to be 18 again
to have all that time?
- Knowing what I know?
- I'll give you 10% just
for the sake of this game,
you get to take 10% of your knowledge
and you get to be 18 starting from zero,
would you take it professionally?
- Okay let me just preface it by saying
I would not trade my life
to go back to 18 ever
because I now know my children exist
and I would never go back.
- I know.
Notice how I hedged it
and said your family life,
take that out.
- Move that out, yeah I'd go back.
- [Gary] Of course you would.
- Yeah I'd go back.
- And this is why all these
18 year olds, 22 year olds,
24 year olds, I'm like--
- Dude, I'd kill the game with 10%.
- One percent, Scooter one percent.
Being you, one percent,
give me one percent.
- Plus my metabolism, crazy.
I could eat whatever I want.
- Jefferson listen, you
need to be patient brother
and you need to bring value to mentors.
People cold email and DM
Scooter and I 24/7, 365,
and they're offering
to take us out to lunch
or drive us from the airport.
It's a ludicrous trade.
It's like laughable.
You need to bring value.
I talk a lot about people
eventually working for people for free.
If I want to be a music mogul,
I swear, I'll say it this way
'cause the team here has made a clip
for me to post on Instagram
of where I say eventually people
are gonna pay me $200,000 to work for me
and I'm not posting it
because it's too douchy in its framework
but I'll say this,
if my 19 year old best friend,
one of my best friends from college
already has an 18 year old,
they had a baby early.
If that kid hit me up right now and said,
"Gary Vee, I'm desperate
to be a music mogul."
I would literally tell him
to hit up his dad Glenn
and pay Scooter to work as
an intern for free for him.
I'm being dead serious.
- You know what's funny
about you saying that?
And it's funny that you say that
for two reasons.
- I believe in it the most.
- No, no listen, it's funny
you say that for two reasons.
One, because I always tell
people when I meet them,
I'm like stop worrying
about getting a job,
create so much value for yourself
that they will not let you go.
And then number two,
just today, and I'm not
gonna tell the story
'cause it's a personal thing,
I saw an opportunity to spend more time
with someone I admire
and I know that the time,
every time I spend time with them,
I get knowledge that makes me better
and I said that I would literally,
I was like, hey, I want to
pay for this for us to go
just because I knew
I was gonna get more
time with that person.
- And that was super flattering
to me when you offered.
But this person was like, no, no, I'll pay
and I was like, no it's on me
and I was fighting it because
I literally truly believe
that every single minute
I spend with someone
who gives me that knowledge
the return is tenfold every single time.
- In the same way that
I tell so many of you
that you need to find
optimism and positivity
'cause that's a mental framework.
Some is wisdom, some is
financial information,
cultural information.
Listen to me, you're looking for mentors,
you need to find people that have done,
Scooter gave you a
great variation of this,
find other people that
did what you wanted,
if you want to be a music mogul,
you should work for free for Scooter Braun
and beg him and pray
and Guyo Siri and Troy Carter
and all these people
that have done things,
it's super smart to bring value,
that's the person you want to be.
What you see under the hood
when you're closest to the sun
is disproportionately valuable,
it's disproportionately valuable.
Cool bro, thanks.
I mean that is like,
I'm so intrigued by this.
I don't know what else to say.
- Me neither, I'm good with that one.
- Alright.
- Are we doing another phone call?
- No, I gotta get out of here.
I gotta run to something.
- No, I want to do one more Gary.
- [Gary] Okay let's do it real fast.
- Let's do one more
because I feel like this next kid,
I used to like--
- It might not be a kid.
- I used to online and I felt like
if I don't answer the next kid,
I miss out on the great one.
- [Gary] Let's go, here we go.
- So I feel like this
next kid might be special,
I'm just feeling something.
- Who was the person you
were looking at on YouTube
prior to, the person right before Justin?
- Oh he was an artist--
- That's so amazing,
you went right into it,
I love you for knowing.
- He was an artist at Akon Hack,
I can't remember his name.
- Hello, this is Brooke.
- Brooke, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
you're on the #AskGaryVee
Show with Scooter Braun.
- [Brooke] Hi, oh my God.
- Brooke, before you do anything,
you need to thank Scooter tremendously.
I'm about to be late for something.
He pushed me 'cause he
has that kind of energy,
you need to really thank
Scooter for this moment.
- [Brooke] Scooter, thank you so much.
- This is it.
- [Brooke] So my name's Brooke Johnson.
- We'll sign you.
- [Brooke] I have applied
for an internship with your company
for several years now
since I got out of college.
- Brooke, Brooke,
this is the greatest moment,
Brooke, you have made my fucking life.
Brooke, good news, no
Brooke, you don't even know,
you've got the job, it's
done, you've got the job,
you're locked in, it's done, it's done.
I will cancel my life to
make this happen, Brooke.
You are an intern in for SB, it's done.
Brooke, I'm telling you, it's done.
No, no, Brooke, say thank you.
Congratulations, Brooke, this is done.
- Brooke where do you live?
- [Brooke] Scooter, so
I went to LA last week,
I bought $100 plane ticket
just to go down there
'cause I was like, hey I'm
gonna get coffee with CEOs
'cause no one's calling,
I've been in Seattle, Washington
actually Dollop, Washington.
- Keep going, Brooke,
this is the moment of my life.
- [Brooke] So I flew down to LA
and I was like, I'm gonna
get some coffee with CEOs
because nobody was biting
on any of my applications,
I was throwing in so many
applications, nothing.
And so I got a few interviews
but when I was down
there I got pickpocketed,
I got my phone stolen,
I got in a really bad car
accident, I got T-boned
and so I went to an intersection--
- Alright, Brooke, first of all,
I'm gonna give you money for
the rights to your story,
I want this movie, keep going.
- Keep going.
- [Brooke] I had the
biggest interview of my life
the next day at nine AM and I--
- Who was it with?
- [Brooke] It was with Adidas.
- Adidas okay.
- [Brooke] I signed an NDA
ao I can't tell you much
but it was a big job
and so they interviewed
me, blah, blah, blah
but I got an email last week,
they're like, "Hey, we're
moving our offices."
So I was like, oh great.
I don't know what to do
and I want to work in LA.
- Brooke, I have a question for
you, what do you want to do?
- [Brooke] I want to change the world.
- I understand that.
- But in details, Brooke,
don't blow your fucking shot here
with some fucking ideology bullshit.
Brooke, do not ideology your fucking life
into the wrong direction.
- Brooke, what kind of
job were you looking for?
- [Brooke] I want to inspire,
I'm looking for marketing,
I want to inspire people
to inspire themselves--
- Okay Brooke, hold on--
- Brooke, you go one more
ideology step and Scooter's gonna kill you
and hang up on you.
Don't give me any more 2019 horseshit.
Get real practical here right now.
This is the moment of your life.
You're gonna watch this video
every day for the rest of your
life and if you do one more
ideological fucking theoretical
bullshit thing here,
when he's looking for practicality,
I'm gonna punch you in the nose.
- Okay Brooke, here's my question for you,
you said marketing,
what gives you experience
in marketing, anything?
- [Brooke] What gives me experience?
Can you repeat that?
- What kind of experience
do you have in marketing?
- What's on the resume,
anything yet or nothing?
- [Brooke] I have a little
bit of marketing experience.
I was the president of the
American Marketing Association
at my university.
I successfully got us
$7,000 through, oh gosh.
- Don't worry, you're fine.
- I'm still here, Brooke.
- [Brooke] I didn't sell anything,
I just went to my yoga class
and I got these women
on board with my ideas
and they're like, yeah,
we'll give you some money.
And so I walked out of the
YMCA one day with $1,000
and it's things like that
I'm really great at.
- Okay Brooke,
so here's my question for you,
just out of curiosity,
give me your background, your parents,
what do they do?
- [Brooke] My mom's a single mom,
my dad's completely out of the picture.
- So Brooke, let me get this
straight. You're a young lady
who I assume with a single mom,
you got student loans?
- [Brooke] Yes, I have a
lot of student loans, yeah.
- So you've got student loans,
you're grinding, you're going to school,
you're making things happen.
You have a dream of marketing.
You buy $100 plane ticket
and just show up in LA.
Somehow you got an interview,
they've decided to move on,
all the other people
wouldn't meet with you,
you got pickpocketed, everything else,
and then how did you find
out about this tonight?
You were just watching Gary's Instagram?
- As everyone does.
- Yeah, one of my friends
told me I needed to follow Gary Vee
'cause he was like, hey Brooke,
get your head out of your
butt and figure it out.
- So Brooke, here's my thing, right,
so I want to explain what happened,
Gary needs to go
and Gary, we just did a call with a guy
and I just said, look,
my whole life experience
it's always been that last
one when I'm about to leave
like answer one more,
that something very special happens.
So we decided you were the
one special and I said,
"Gary, one more."
So that's why he was
saying everything else.
So what I'm saying to you is
I get in a lot of trouble with my staff
when I meet people in the street
and they ask for an
internship and I say yes.
I have literally--
- D. Rock's super pissed
with me right now 'cause I just did it.
- You listen, I am actually told
I'm not allowed to do that anymore
by my own company
because I get in so much trouble
for giving random int,
and usually they turn out to not
always be a good intern.
- Yeah, they're always shit,
they're always shit.
- [Brooke] Oh no, I'm a good investment.
- No I know, it's always shit
but don't worry, though.
- It's usually always shit
but it's worked out a couple times.
- And one time fucking
nets out and guess what?
That's why Scooter and
I have fucking companies
not the fucking henchmen
here in the corner.
- So here's what I'm
gonna say to you, Brooke,
when do you graduate?
- I already did.
- Yeah, she's ready
to fucking roll, Scooter.
- Okay and you want to
work for free, you said?
You just want an internship?
- Well minimum wage wouldn't be terrible.
- [Brooke] I will work for free.
I'm planning on moving down
to Los Angeles within the week
regardless of if I get a job or not.
- What about money to live?
How you gonna afford to live in LA?
- [Brooke] I have a cousin
who told me that I can rent a
room for 350 in Santa Clarita
and I was like, okay I'll take that up.
I don't know what--
- Fucking figure it out, Brooke.
Eat shit, eat fucking shit.
- Brooke, here's what we're gonna do,
I'm gonna get your information,
I'm breaking my rule,
this is not for any kid watching,
you meet me in the street,
I'm not breaking my rule again,
don't get it twisted.
- This is never
happening again.
- But what I'm gonna tell you is I follow,
the universe has fixed
my life plenty of times,
I was telling Gary earlier,
when I don't really know
sometimes it shows it for me,
you need a break
and I think sometimes in life,
I was talking to Gary--
- Brooke, start
fucking crying.
- Brooke, I want to explain this,
I was talking to Gary about luck earlier
and what I mean by that is,
and I never got to explain it,
I have friends who I
know are as smart as me
and have worked as hard as me
and have not had the success in life
because along the way,
they just didn't get the breaks.
And I always tell them,
keep going, the breaks
are waiting for you,
the breaks are waiting for you,
sometimes it happens earlier in life,
I got lucky, it happened early in life
and sometimes it happens later in life.
- And sometimes it happens
on the #AskGaryVee Show.
- And I think tonight happened
So I don't know what it will turn into
but you deserve a break
so I'm not giving you a job yet
but I'm gonna give you the internship.
And what I'm gonna do is--
- We're gonna pay you
minimum wage too, Brooke.
- But unlike the other interns,
I'm gonna actually make sure
that you and I,
that I put you on a couple projects
to make sure that I see what you can do
on the marketing side
and that's why
we did the extra phone call.
- And Brooke,
even better, it gets way better,
because I'm not letting
Scooter here out Oprah me,
so on top of that,
because you want to do marketing,
I'm flying you,
I'm paying for all this shit,
I'm flying you to New York,
I'm putting you up in a hotel for a week
and/or at D. Rock's house, I
haven't figured it out yet,
and you're gonna work here
at Vayner for a week--
- But what if I want to hire her?
- No, no, no, stick with me real quick,
you're gonna work with my team for a week,
we're gonna give you all the secret sauce
so that when you go
back to Scooter's land,
you're not just doing some YMCA hustle,
you're doing 2019 perfect marketing.
You're coming here for a week,
we're gonna teach you as
much as we can in a week,
you're gonna work 19 hours
a day like our crew does,
then you're gonna go
back to Scooter's world
and eventually be the CMO of
fucking Scooter Braun Projects.
- So Brooke, we're gonna figure this out.
The one thing I want you to
promise me though if we do this,
you gotta only promise we one thing--
- [Brooke] I'm all ears.
- Okay.
I just want you to call
your mom when you're done
and thank her because I'm
raising kids with two parents
and it's hard already
and the fact that your
mom has been a single mom
and raised someone with
this kind of ambition,
that's a beautiful thing
and she probably put a lot of sacrifice in
that you don't even know,
so I just want you to call
her and say thank you,
I caught a break tonight.
I don't know what it'll turn into
but I could hear you need a break
so you got your break tonight.
- And Brooke, and I got one request,
are you a Seahawks fan?
- [Brooke] Well I know
you guys are Jets fans,
but yeah, go Hawks man.
- You now have to become
a New York Jets fan,
like right now.
There's nothing else to say,
Russell is a great guy,
Pete Carroll, former Jets coach
but right here right now
you have to tell the world
you are now
a New York Jets fan.
- Do you have her information?
- [Brooke] Would you guys trade
your football team for this?
- I would not, but good news,
I can do anything with myself.
I would not.
- Hold on, hold on,
Gary, hold on, hold on,
I don't want you to answer this, Brooke,
I need to say something,
now I really like you,
the problem with football fans
and this is why as a Jets fan
I respect Eagles fans and other people
is that there are all these people
that are only fans when they're wining,
they're fair weather fans,
Jets fans we've been hearing
about Joe Willie Namath
our entire lives,
we're real fans, we fight.
The fact that she just got this break
and still had the guts--
- That was guts.
- To tell us, I'm staying a Seahawks fan,
Brooke, I fuck with you.
- Brooke, on the other hand, I don't
so I'm taking everything
I offered off the table,
no New York, no D. Rock house,
no flight here,
you have to go straight to Scooter's world
and you can knock on YMCA doors
and fucking sell some albums,
I don't fucking know.
I'm out, Scooter's in.
- [Brooke] I'll fly into your office.
Don't worry, I'll figure out a way.
- I'm kidding.
Listen, I'm super excited.
- This is why we took the last phone call,
this is exactly
the kind of stuff I do.
- Andy's gonna send you
a message right now to your Facebook
with my email.
We'll get set up,
we'll forward it to Scooter's land.
She's gonna come here for a
week, we're gonna train her.
Yeah, we'll put her up
for a week and train her
and then we'll send her back
to you with more talent.
- And then I'm gonna pay for
the flight to LA from there
and then you move into your cousin's
and we'll start the internship.
- [Brooke] Oh my God.
- And Brooke, I'm gonna
buy you a $4,000 car.
- You're really Oprah.
- I'm being dead serious,
she can't get to your
fucking office without a car.
I don't know what 4,000 gets
you in car world these days.
- You want to split it?
- Done.
Brooke, we're buying you a $4,000 car.
- By the way, my office
is gonna be really pissed
that I'm just giving out cars
and they've been working there.
They're be like, what the fuck?
- Brooke, Brooke, I'm gonna hang up now
because I'm about to buy you a house.
And so congratulations Brooke,
fucking Scooter made your life.
- By the way, it's also Uber and Lyft.
- Yeah I know, but let's get her a car.
I want her to drive a $4,000 car
'cause there's a little
bit of that ghetto magic
that I'm interested in.
I want the hustle.
- Do you get to choose it?
- Yeah, it's green
but not that teal bullshit up in Seattle.
It's hunter green.
Brooke, we're buying you a fucking car,
you've got a job,
you work for Scooter,
you're fucking coming and
getting fucking IP from Vayner,
shit's good tonight.
- [Brooke] Oh my God.
- Are you crying, laughing or throwing up?
- [Brooke] I'm smile crying.
- Awesome, we love you Brooke.
Scooter, you're amazing,
see ya.
- Take care.
That's why we do the extra phone call.
- I get it.
I'm not even doing a question of the day.
That was the fucking ending of the day.
I love you, brother, always.
I'll see you soon, that
was amazing, see ya, bye.
- Take care.
(upbeat music)